retour l'actualité d'abord aux mystères
de marseille l'assassinât du maire
socialiste du 7e secteur de la ville
s'ajoutent à la longue liste des
affaires criminelles marseillaise
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan presque en
état de guerre le nouveau bilan fait
état de 58 morts et près de 200 blessés
à tourcoing il n'y avait pas de fumée
sans feu
l'atelier de confection ravagé par
l'incendié était le prototype de
l'atelier clandestin
enfin inculpation dans la drôme de 5,5 6
termiste pour avoir nature naturalisés
des oiseaux d'espèce protégée il risque
jusqu'à six mois de prison ferme a battu
hier soir au volant de sa voiture le
docteur peschard maire socialiste du 7e
secteur de marseille est mort comme un
voyou 10 aujourd'hui
incrédule bon nombre de marseillais
exclu pour le moment aucune piste
magouilles politiques ou histoire
sentimentale on parle beaucoup sur la
canebière en tout cas un meurtre
peut-être à rapprocher d'autres affaires
criminelles survenu dans le milieu
hospitalier marseillais daniel jamet
place durant à sainte marie hier soir
peu avant minuit jean jacques béchard
sort du restaurant le refuge est tombé
dans un guet-apens deux hommes
vraisemblablement masqués et armés de
fusils à pompe attendent le maire du 7e
secteur de marseille dans un véhicule
il tire la voiture de leur victime fait
une embardée et s'écrase contre un mur
jean jacques béchard est pratiquement
mort sur le coup les témoins du meurtre
sont rares mais les enquêteurs
établissent tout de même des portraits
robots et dans le quartier même la
rumeur rappelle l'assassinât il ya
quelques mois du directeur de la
polyclinique nord où travaillent et
aussi jean jacques béchard ce matin les
mairies d'arrondissement comme l'hôtel
de ville était gardée par la police
une cellule de crise se serait constitué
dans la nuit et le docteur peschard
avais tu pour guide en politique gaston
defferre
il figurait maintenant parmi les fidèles
de robert vigouroux il était donc maire
des quartiers défavorisés du nord de
marseille 14e et 15e arrondissements et
avait pour objectif de faire baisser la
délinquance
on les connaissait par ailleurs on
croyez lui connaître une vie privée
compliquée pour mieux comprendre sa
personnalité
le portrait daniel jamet
chirurgien de son état jean jacques
béchard était entré au conseil municipal
de marseille en 1974 il devait assumer
pendant trois ans de 83 à 81 6 la charge
de délégué à la protection médicale et à
l'hygiène
jean-jacques pêcheurs compter parmi les
fidèles de gaston defferre et à la mort
de celui-ci il a opté sans hésiter en
faveur de robert vigouroux élu en mars
1989 sur la liste majorité marseillaise
conduite par robert vigouroux
jean-jacques pêcheurs avaient subi comme
lui les foudres du ps des bouches du
rhône en tant que maire du 7e secteur de
marseille son action était résolument
tourné vers les populations défavorisées
il était notamment à l'origine d'un
relais du coeur une sorte de supermarché
ou les bénéficiaires du rmi peuvent
acquérir un repas au prix symbolique de
1 franc
enfin dans le cadre de ses
responsabilités municipales jean jacques
béchard était l'un des quatre membres
élus de la commission d'urbanisme de la
ville
sur le plan professionnel le chirurgien
peschard exercer désormais exclusivement
à la clinique florence
il avait opéré quelques fois par le
passé à la polyclinique du nord mais
selon les gérants de l'établissement ils
n'en étaient pas actionnaires
le nom de jean jacques béchard avait été
évoquée par contre à propos d'un autre
fait divers la disparition de sa
secrétaire il y a cinq ans
cette affaire n'a jamais été élucidé et
quoi qu'il en soit pas quasiment au même
moment marseille un règlement de comptes
a eu lieu hier soir dans la clinique
heureusement trois personnes ont été
blessées dont l'une très sérieusement il
s'agit de gendrey simeoni connu des
services de police ce meurtre intervient
après la mort de plusieurs individus
tout aussi habitué de l'hôtel de police
les enquêteurs n'explique toujours pas
l'agitation qui règne en ce moment dans
le milieu marseillais
l'actualité à l'étranger à présent dans
le caucase aujourd'hui les troupes
soviétiques qui envoyait donc par moscou
se sont déployés pour tenter de stopper
les affrontements entre azéri et
arménien des affrontements qui selon un
nouveau bilan officiel publié ce soir
par moscou aurait déjà fait 58 morts et
près de 200 blessés
oui malgré l'instauration
de pardon d'urgence malgré la présence
de plus de dix mille soldats soviétiques
la situation demeure explosive en
arménie plusieurs dépôts d'armes ont
continué à être attaqué par des
manifestants le point de la situation
avec elisabeth sladen au terme du
deuxième jours d'état d'urgence dans le
caucase
la situation est explosive un nouveau
bilan des victimes fait état de 58 morts
et 69 blessés hostiles à l'état
d'urgence les nationalistes azéri ont
manifesté dans plusieurs villes pour
réclamer la démission des autorités
d'azerbaïdjan et le droit de revendiquer
si besoin par les armes le haut karabagh
pour entraver la progression des chars
soviétiques là le centre de bakou les
habitants dressent des barricades avec
des voitures en quelques jours un
millier d'appartements au résident à des
arméniens ont été saccagés pillés
l'un des deux émissaires du kremlin à
bas coût à négocier durant deux jours
avec le pouvoir local l'ordre de tirer
sur les auteurs de violences contre les
arméniens 5000 d'entre eux ont quitté
bas coût dans les dernières 24 heures
et l'exode massif continue par la mer la
géorgie où l'arménie à yerevan 2500
réfugiés avec chaque jour traumatisé
rescapés et bt aux révoltés des pogroms
soixante dix mille personnes ont
manifesté hier soir contre l'état
d'urgence dans la région de goris zone
stratégique par où l'on n'achemine toute
l'aide arménienne ou nagorny karabach
aux frontières du haut karabagh les
combattants affluent près de 2000 hommes
armés d'artillerie lourde aurait pris
position dans la montagne
déterminé à entraver l'arrivée des
troupes d'interposition soviétique
autour des villages arméniens ont
encerclé les combats font encore rage ce
soir d'autres images de l'actualité à
l'étranger elles sont commentées pour
nous par laurence piquet
le prix sakharov des droits de l'homme
ont mis à sac bourreau faire du
printemps de prague alexandre do check
aujourd'hui président de l'assemblée
tchécoslovaque
il appelle l'europe à soutenir les
réformes de gorbatchev s'agira au
président de la commission européenne
jacques delors il propose que la cee
accorde chaque année une aide financière
accrue aux pays de l'est catastrophe
écologique dans l'archipel de madère au
large du maroc depuis lundi soir plus de
50 50 tonnes de pétrole sont venus
souillé les côtes de l'île de porto
santo les responsables portugais ont
acheminé par avion des produits
dissolvant l'origine de cette marée
noire restent mystérieuses
redistribution complète des cartes dans
le processus de paix au cambodge
à l'issue d'une réunion de deux jours à
paris ce sont les cinq membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu qui prennent en main les
opérations au mois d'août dernier les
quatre factions cambodgienne s'étaient
montrés incapables de s'entendre
enfin rostropovitch et sa femme retrouve
la citoyenneté soviétique par décret du
soviet suprême
exilé depuis 74 le violoncelliste
retournera le mois prochain en urss pour
effectuer une série de concerts il ne
sera satisfait dit il que lorsque seul
génie signe lui aussi sera rendu à son
peuple
sélim hoss le premier ministre musulman
du liban veut remplacer un grand nombre
d'ambassadeurs libanais et notamment
celui de paris monsieur x turc un homme
proche des thèses du général chrétien
michel aoun
oui cela fait maintenant depuis une
semaine que des partisans du général
aoun occupent l'ambassade du liban à
paris pour le moment les autorités
françaises n'entendent pas intervenir
jean marc pitte
cela fait maintenant une semaine que les
partisans du général aoun occupent
l'ambassade du liban à paris ils
protestent ainsi contre la décision du
premier ministre sélim hoss de remplacer
les ambassadeurs actuellement en poste
dans les pays occidentaux par des
diplomates prétendument prosyriens le
personnel de l'ambassade en congé forcé
à abandonner les locaux de la rue
copernic aux manifestants ici c'est le
bureau de l'ambassadeur de l'iba cette
nuit froide turc l'actuel ambassadeur a
informé ses drôles de squatters ce que
selim hoss avait demandé au ministère
des affaires étrangères français de les
évacuer par la force si nécessaire celle
heymans d'abord nous ne le connaissons
pas en tant que gouvernement il n'a
aucun droit de demander de nous de nous
déloger de notre territoire nous sommes
nous resterons ici nous sommes à
l'ambassade depuis une semaine nous
resterons le temps qu'il faut ils seule
personne dans le monde pourra vous faire
sortir de cette ambassade
c'est michel harmand pers
vous avez eu michel aoun au téléphone ce
matin nous avons eu le jeu elles rendent
notre commandant en chef et notre prix
mist au téléphone ce matin
et quel est exactement son message de
tenir jusqu'au bout que nous sommes
responsables du prince de sur une rame à
paris l'affrontement entre les crs et
les libanais de paris semble ce soir
évitez roland dumas le ministre des
affaires étrangères a démenti
aujourd'hui avoir reçu une telle demande
de selim hoss les partisans daoud
dormiront certainement ce soir encore
rue copernic entre les internes et chefs
de clinique en grève et le ministre de
la santé claude evin
un accord est intervenu la nuit dernière
mais un accord qui ne règle rien
puisqu'en fait la base dans les
différents services hospitaliers n'a pas
ce soir vraiment accepté de cesser son
mouvement
oui partout en france des assemblées
générales se tiennent encore écouter
plutôt l'ont bien cet après midi dont
plusieurs hôpitaux parisiens le
reportage dé dominique dumas ambiance de
franche explication ce matin à la salle
de garde de l'hôpital saint-antoine
entre interne grévistes un représentant
du comité degrés malgré les nouvelles
rassurantes sur une plate forme d'accord
entre le ministre de la santé et ce
comité
le doute s'installe certains internes et
chefs de clinique s'interroge si la
liberté du lieu d'installation semble
acquise est plutôt satisfaisante en
revanche l'interrogation demeure pour
revaloriser le secteur 1 et dégeler le
secteur 2 un des jeunes qui autoriserait
l'accès de nouveaux praticiens à une
tarification plus libre cela permettrait
selon les internes travaillent dans de
meilleures conditions et donc plus
soignée secteur 2 sera aménagé en fait
essentiellement pour les collègues
tchèques
et éventuellement pour les inter nous on
voudrait que ce soit aménagé pour les
chefs depuis les intérêts des l'ensemble
des médecins pour pratiquer une médecine
libérale
la réponse au ministre ne devrait pas
tarder les interdirons si il continue la
grève ou si ils reprennent le travail
réponse à coup sûr dans soir 3 hier
matin à tourcoing dans le nord un
incendie ravage est un atelier de
confection sur place une fois éteintes
les flammes
nos camarades de faire 3 lille se sont
dit que cet atelier là avait tout à fait
l'alluré d'un atelier clandestin depuis
hier ils ont mené leur enquête et ce
soir leurs doutes se confirme les
scénarios et si l'on peut dire classique
le propriétaire un asiatique et
légalement inscrit sur le registre du
commerce
mais aucun de ses salariés nés déclaré
une affaire qui marche qui alimente les
stocks d'une célèbre chaîne de magasins
franchisés une affaire connue même des
services du tribunal de commerce
l'enquète de l'udc la gamme bauchi tout
commence mardi matin par un banal feu de
poubelle pourtant l'immeuble qui a brûlé
renfermait un atelier bien particulier
une go confection les 25 employés qui
travaillaient était en effet logés sur
place ils dormaient dans des boxes à
côté des machines à coudre bien son
mandat et vitrail pour moi et ils
viennent de la région parisienne de loi
tout ça ils n'ont pas logement et pour
trouver un logement ici c'est pas passé
et on attend ses approvisionnements pour
loger un côté de l'immeuble qui a brûlé
un autre immeuble et à l'intérieur un
autre atelier de confection une
différence quand même ici chez les young
les employés ne sont pas logés sur place
en plus des patrons il y a huit salariés
dont 1 et civp qui a été placée par la
mission locale de la mairie de tourcoing
tout a donc l'air parfaitement légale
d'ailleurs monsieur young est inscrit au
registre des métiers
il paye ses ouvrières au smic et ils
cotisent à l'urssaf
pourtant les conditions de sécurité ne
sont pas les meilleures précision les
délais de fabrication sont extrêmement
courts et le travail se fait uniquement
sur commande pour les grossistes de la
région s'est enraillée havraise montana
vinifera
j'ai fait des pantalons je fais à
prophète 4 500 par jour tous les mois le
transporteur qui vient chercher des
applications ce qui nous fournit des
tissus et et nous livrer dtcc et vous
vous demandez combien le pantalon la
société qui hérite des pantalons à 13
francs l'unité n'est guère bavarde ni
sur le prix de revente ni sur les
conditions de travail chez les sous
traitants
le responsable se bornent seulement a
répété que les ateliers de confection
sont légaux le reste ce n'est pas son
affaire
plus surprenant l'inspection du travail
se refuse à tout commentaire alors que
c'est elle qui contrôle les ateliers à
tourcoing il ya donc un malaise moral
bien sûr mais aussi économiques
quand on voit des gens qui je dirais je
serais tenté de dire trahi nuitées jours
et pour un salaire misérable puisque
lorsqu'on sait qu'un pantalon sortie de
fabrication est revendu 16 francs
comment voulez-vous d'un autre côté que
le textile français ne n'en subit pas
les conséquences dramatiques qu'on
connaît actuellement au niveau des
grosses entreprises qui licencient 16
francs le pantalon disais donc cet élu
de tourcoing belette martin-pêcheur
buses ou mouflon une centaine d'animaux
naturalisés la plupart représentants
d'espèces protégées
eh bien tous ces animaux vient d'être
saisie dans la drôme la gendarmerie fait
de valence
associé au garde-chasse a permis
d'arrêter ce trafic tout à fait légale
les cinq taxidermiste inculpés risquent
jusqu'à six mois de prison ferme de lyon
malkin de pradier chouette effraie
pic-vert faucon creissels chamois ou
castor la chasse a été fructueuse pour
la brigade de recherches de valence qui
a mis la main sur 76 animaux empaillés
tous d'espèces protégées lors de quatre
perquisitions dans le département de la
drôme un seul taxidermiste est
officiellement répertoriés dans la drôme
et c'est ce qui met la puce à l'oreille
des gardes-chasse il constatait
régulièrement sur le terrain la
disparition de spécimens protéger puis
ils ont réellement démanteler la filière
grâce aux renseignements de chasseurs
excédé par les pratiques illégales de
certains d'entre eux l'interpellation
des taxidermistes mettra un holà à la
décimation d
peste mais les protecteurs de la nature
voit dans cette prise le maillon d'un
trafic chute d'ampleur internationale
surtout pour le gros gibier se tue dans
la drôme où 400 à 600 chevreuil par an
or le ou les deux taxidermiste officiel
déclaré honnête du département de la
drôme
en naturalise bon quelques dizaines donc
on passe les autres passez votre oeuf
les cinq taxidermiste clandestins ont
été laissés en liberté sous contrôle
judiciaire
l' enquête de la gendarmerie se poursuit
voici à présent le tour de france de
l'actualité avec les images des 25
stations à 3 et les commentaires de
nathalie et r triple meurtre aujourd'hui
à toulouse peu avant midi un homme a
assassiné à coups de chevrotine le
patron d'un bar avant de tuer à bout
portant deux jeunes gens dans leur
appartement
peu après les faits le meurtrier a été
arrêté mais on ignore encore les mobiles
de son geste
un règlement de comptes entre
toxicomanes n'est pas exclue
le rpr ne soutiendra pas à la liste de
michel mouillot à l'élection municipale
partielle de cannes en marche
89 michel mouillot udf p r était élu de
justesse que le scrutin a été validé en
raison de tracts diffamatoires envers
anne marie dupuy maire sortant rpr
aujourd'hui le rpr estime que michel
mouillot n'a pas respecté ses
engagements
il ne soutiendra donc aucune lice le 28
janvier prochain
390 mètres de long 71 de large
les sauts pacifique vient d'arriver au
havre motifs relancer l'activité et le
dynamisme du port pétrolier de haute
normandie
les sauts pacifique peut contenir
jusqu'à 500 mille tonnes c'est l'un des
quatre plus grands pétroliers du monde
construit en 1976 il avait cessé toute
activité depuis quatre ans aujourd'hui
les sauts pacifique est à nouveau
opérationnel voilà cette édition du 19
20 en direct de la péniche thalassa se
termine ce soir sur la chaîne et bien
hommage samuel beckett catherine avec
une très belle pièce en attendant godot
20h35 avec notamment romane polanski et
rufus et puis prochain rendez vous de
l'information sur la torah sur l'a3 soir
3 à 22h55 présenté par philippe destin
merci tout de suite la météo complète de
michel tour et on se retrouvera demain
et
conte